foreign
[Music]
briefing for Wednesday December 7th I'm
Zoe Thomas for The Wall Street Journal
today we are talking about chat GPT a
state-of-the-art conversational AI model
developed by openai chat GPT is capable
of engaging in human-like conversations
providing answers to questions and even
generating original content
that little introduction was written by
chat GPT itself after just a short
prompt from Maine the artificial
intelligence chat bot is suddenly
everywhere reaching a million users on
Monday just a week after it was released
according to its maker open AI
openai also created Dolly an AI platform
that creates images including some
award-winning images based on users
prompts and those aren't the only AI
programs becoming internet Sensations
but the popularity and sophistication of
these programs also raises questions
about how they could be used or misused
joining us to dive into that is our
personal Tech reporter and Maria
Alcantara hi Anne-Marie thanks for
joining us Hey Zoe thanks as always for
having me so let's start talking about
chat GPT can you just describe what it
is for any listeners you haven't come
across it yet so first of all chat gbt
is a tongue twister as you can tell very
hard to say uh really fast but most
importantly it's a free AI chat bot
really you can ask it anything and
everything you can ask it you know basic
questions that you would Google too even
asking it to write a love song for you
and it'll spit out an answer and you'll
get a different response every time you
ask something
okay so for anyone who hasn't tried it
out yet can you tell us what you know
some prompts people are putting in and
the kind of answers that chat GPT is
generating
yes so you can ask it really any type of
question you want as for example we've
asked it if unicorns exist and it said
you know a very nice little answer that
unicorns are a fictional character are
most likely don't exist others have
asked it you know really deep questions
such as you know when will I die and
it'll tell you it can't answer for you
because it just doesn't make those types
of predictions and other questions that
people have asked also include very
existential ones such as you know who am
I and the chatbot will respond and tell
you it can't answer that for you and
like only you can Define yourself and
who you are so it can be deep it can be
funny it can be serious it can really be
anything you want it to be
so those are some like really
existential questions what about some of
the more creative prompts that people
are putting in yeah so the other day I
asked the chatbot to write me an essay
about quantum physics and Pokemon two
very unrelated topics and the chatbot
spit out a great essay about what
quantum physics is what Pokemon is and
how they actually relate to each other
even though one is rooted in reality and
the other one's you know a fictional
character and so people have been asking
it questions like that people have tried
to get it to solve homework questions
Engineers who work in computer science
have also tried to you know figure out
problems and solutions that they've been
having in their work day and finding
responses to that as well
how is it coming up with these answers
so chat GPT was trained on massive
amounts of data that the company has
gathered from the internet and other
sources through 2021 and as you can
imagine that's just it's infinite you
know what doesn't the internet have out
there Wikipedia alone has so much
information right so it's kind of
trained itself on that information and
pulling from that to answer your
questions are there limitations to these
answers there are some limitations like
I described sometimes it won't tell you
a response because it can't or you know
it's too essential some of the other
limitations people have come across is
that the chat bot will tell you
information that isn't correct and you
know maybe you're a scholar and you know
that for a fact let's talk a little more
broadly about AI software because chat
GPT isn't the only one that's taking off
what else is out there and what is
behind all of its popularity
some other interesting AI tools that
have popped up include lenza which is
this app that is at the top of the App
Store charts right now and it sort of
takes photos that you feed it and makes
a beautiful artistic photo some of it's
like really space like some of it feels
like it's out of Middle Earth another
one that went popular a few months ago
was Dolly 2 which is a similar function
to lensa where it takes things you've
written down like podcaster in space
recording a session and it'll turn that
into an image and really what's driving
all of this is that these AI tools are
now being
given to the public given to the
everyday person and you don't need to
have a degree in advanced you know
artificial intelligence or computer
science to know how to use them you can
just do exactly what we're describing
put in whatever prompt you want and see
what the results are
I mean if everybody has access to these
it does raise a lot of questions about
how it could be used I mean difficulties
say for for teachers if students use
these to write essays or you know even
for people making a living for artists
or you know journalists trying to write
stories
those concerns have definitely been
raised with all of these types of
products and many AI experts that I've
spoken to have said that we should view
some of these tools not as a goodbye to
those roles and professions but more so
as an enabler of enhancing your work so
if you have writer's block
you could type in a prompt and see what
it tells you and then maybe that'll you
know get the juices flowing in your own
brain naturally if you're a student
maybe it'll help you understand the
question better and come to your own
conclusions and answers of course people
will probably use it in ways they
shouldn't but we'll see how what you
know guard rails end up being put in
place to make sure that these things
aren't abused in the ways that they
definitely could be
all right that's our personal Tech
reporter Anne Muriel Cantera thanks so
much for joining us thanks and that's it
for today's Tech news briefing for more
Tech stories check out our website
wsj.com
I'm Zoe Thomas for The Wall Street
Journal
thanks for listening
[Music]
[Music]